they sure
[Music]
karate kid fans span generations and now
with the kobrakai spin-off
johnny and danny are reaching a whole
new audience if you're as obsessed as we
are
we got you covered we headed behind the
scenes and dug up some of the series
best bloopers that'll keep you
entertained until cobra guy's next
binge-worthy season hits netflix
oh [ __ ] that's right you felt like a
champ
cobra kai has given us a completely
different side of johnny lawrence
thanks to his teenage neighbor miguel
and him reopening a revamped version of
the kobrakai dojo
johnny is a whole new man however if
this blooper had made it to the final
cut we'd be watching an entirely
different show
that's why i'm opening up cobra kai so
we can fight back
take down no i'm not opening out of
cobra kai am i looks like ralph macchio
was a little jealous danny wasn't the
one to open cobra kai
no probably no that would change the
whole show could there be a rivalry
between the two actors
off screen as well or maybe it was just
a monday on set
what do cobra kai and musicals have in
common
no not a corny storyline that we can't
help but fall in love with
choreography we're not saying that danny
and johnny were meant to break out and
dance numbers every other scene
we're talking about their fighting
choreography the actors spend a lot of
time practicing these fights before
filming them
and sometimes well they just don't go
according to plan
especially for a lot of the younger cast
ouch
oh what actors do to make their
characters come to life
john crease may put up a good front but
johnny wasn't giving up his version of
cobra kai without a fight
he literally got thrown into one of the
dojo's glass walls
in the final cut the moment happened
seamlessly but before they could call
cut on that scene
there was one take where johnny's actor
william actually got bits of the
shattered mirror in his mouth
and proceeded to dramatically spit them
out don't worry though
we're sure it wasn't real glass it is
movie magic after all
i don't want to fight i just want to
talk
how about what for some reason roller
ranks have made a comeback and are full
of teens trying to unearth the nostalgic
80s vibes
we have to admit seeing samantha larusso
and robbie keen at one did give us
all the feels however it was much less
romanticized behind the scenes
we hate to break it to you but
samantha's actress mary master just
couldn't keep her balance
it's amazing that they even got anything
filmed
okay one more time robbie's actor tanner
buchanan thought it was hilarious at
least
seeing danny and johnny's relationship
transform from what it was in the
original karate kid movies
is nothing short of pretty cool but this
behind the scenes moment gave us a look
into what their relationship off screen
is like
it's pretty hilarious to see ralph so in
character that he squared up as soon as
william
threatened him william of course thought
his flinching was hilarious
we got a flincher these two sure have
come a long way together
this blooper might just be the most
dramatic one yet sure
seeing johnny and danny together is
great but can we take a second to talk
about the chemistry between the younger
cast
miguel and robbie took the cake for best
behind the scenes moment with this one
are you the dude that was hugging my dad
are you kidding me right now
oh i know you're not dad don't walk my
dad it's safe to say that this
fight quickly took an unexpected turn
well miguel
are you hugging his dad what other way
is there to have a drink off besides
standing on one foot on a stool samantha
and tori taught us that much
like tori actress peyton list had a
tough time holding her drinks
literally we see that behind the scenes
she was actually attached to a wire to
keep her still
and control her fall when the time came
but even with the wire's help
she just couldn't keep her balance
somebody couldn't hold her licker huh
of course miguel and johnny's
relationship is a lot like the one we
saw between danny and mr miyagi
so of course the show had to include
scenes of miguel using his training
like that one epic forest fight between
him and hawke
except if you take a look at the
bloopers you'll see the fight was
anything but serious
hilarious yes looks like the two actors
had a lot of fun on set that day
who wouldn't why don't you why did you
steal them out and the samantha versus
tony rivalry continues
samantha may have bested tony in the
drinking challenge
but she was the one who fell in this
scene to be more specific she was
actually pushed into a table full of
food
it did not look very comfortable when we
saw it happen on our screens
but behind the scenes it looks like mary
actually enjoyed getting thrown into the
table
it tastes good the roller rank and table
incident weren't the only time mary had
difficulty staying upright while filming
in this blooper she completely ruined
the take by tripping over what looks
like
absolutely nothing what's even more
hilarious is that she wasn't even the
main character of the scene
tanner once again found the whole
situation hilarious
and ralph may have gotten his monologue
disrupted but
he didn't seem to mind it was actually
monday this time
it's a monday with how big the movies
were for ralph's career and just the
world in general
we don't blame ralph for having a hard
time letting go of the karate kid
or just constantly thinking about it
because it looks like that's
exactly what happened in this blooper i
almost said karate kid
yep he almost called danny's daughter
karate kid honestly we aren't mad
it's kind of cute what do you say to a
new nickname samantha
i'm so kind of freaked out about it i
feel guilty about just driving away
you know that feeling or those days when
technology just isn't going your way
well it happens on tv sets a lot whether
it's an interrupting car alarm or a cell
phone that someone forgot to put on
silent it can get
super disruptive during filming most of
the time it's hilarious
especially the way william handles the
intrusions purposely attack your
opponent's injury
do you hear that take a look at some of
the best times it happened to the cobra
kai cast
it just goes to show us how professional
these actors are
that nothing throws them off all right
he's a better man than you will ever be
that's a nice phone i like it william
might be as professional as they come
but that doesn't mean he doesn't
sometimes make mistakes especially when
the script includes a crazy tongue
twister like this one
thanks for giving her an extra kick in
the pants thanks for giving her next
advance
he of course eventually got it perfect
we saw it happen in the show
but this blooper shows us that these
actors are truly
just humans doing their best hashtag
relatable
we're laughing and i screw up my land
sometimes it just
isn't your day whether it's a monday or
even a tuesday
but that doesn't mean we can't make some
of these actors clubs into
pure comedy william isn't the only one
who had
trouble with some of his lines the
youngest cast and ralph himself had some
funny stumblings as well
what oh i was going to take him out to
the
dog
here's a compilation that'll really get
you laughing hey
you wouldn't want to go to the beach
with me next time you think memorizing
and reading from a script is easy
come back to this compilation it has
precision
i didn't get it we haven't gotten behind
the scenes bloopers from cobra kai
season 3 just yet but the actors have
been giving us sneak peeks into what the
season
looked like behind the scenes with their
hilarious tick tocks enjoy
we sure did this cast truly has a bond
like no other
so funny miss robinson it's a snake do
what's a snake do wax on wax off wax
behind the scenes
should be cobra guy's new motto how epic
were those bloopers
is it just us or did they completely
change how you think about the show
we can't wait to head back to netflix
and re-watch all of our favorite
episodes what was your favorite behind
the scenes moment
drop a comment below and let's chat
about cobra kai if you want more cobra
kai content
make sure to give this video a thumbs up
we'd also love to see you in another
video so
make sure to crane kick that subscribe
button catch you later
[Music]